here's a map of the uh
the part that we're interested in a
small part of a very big country and i
guess we're going to get fairly familiar
with this map in the weeks to come the
military logic of it is pretty clear the
russians would like to draw effectively
a military line pushing south from
kharkiv to meet up going north from
marriott to produce a sort of straight
line between kharkiv and mario paul and
isolate that
salient which is to the east of that
line and we've marked on the map here
all the places where intensive fighting
has been recorded over the last uh 24
hours so there's been intensive fighting
in chuhev in isiam in siverio dionyez in
popasna and in marinka and those are all
the areas where the ukrainians are
trying to hold the russian advance
because what the russians want to do
draw this north-south line and then push
from the areas they already hold from
the east towards the west to meet up
with that line now
that sounds pretty logical if you say it
quickly however there are some uh
caveats to all of that and it's not as
never as simple as it as it always
sounds first of all the distances are
pretty big 300 miles from north to south
so there's a lot of offensive to conduct
here secondly
i think the russians have got off to a
rolling start it doesn't seem to me as
if they've got off to what would not you
normally expect is a sort of hammer blow
start get get everything in place and
then really go
i think probably i'm guessing under
pressure from the kremlin they've got
off to a rolling start because they're
under pressure to produce something
pretty quickly and that's why the
ukrainians have been quite successful
certainly over the last day and a half
at holding these russian pushes
east to west in the way that they have
second problem is that the russians have
been counter-attacked the ukrainians are
not just holding them so far but they're
counter-attacking particularly around
southeast of kharkiv between kharkiv and
tuna here
and north of kharkiv there's a direct
line you can't see it on this map
between kharkiv and belgarot in russia
which is where most of the supplies are
coming from and the ukrainians are
attacking those communication lines to
try to prevent material getting through
and then finally of course
there is mariupol
in the south
in truth the russians have mario paul
they control it they control the whole
city
but there at the avistar steel works
there seem to be a thousand fifteen
hundred members of the ukrainian armed
forces who will not surrender they seem
to be in the tunnels and the bomb
shelters and the caverns underneath the
steel works which are pretty
considerable
and so those elements of the azo brigade
the 56 mechanized infantry the tenth
assault brigade
however many of them are left are under
there
and they seem to have decided that
nothing remains but to fight
and there is a military logic to that
because as long as they refuse to
surrender although their fate is now
fixed as long as they refuse to
surrender they are tying up russian
troops who otherwise would be going
north to try to build this line between
mario paul and karkov so there is a
military logic but of course there is
also a political and moral logic to all
of this
because they are now the epitome they
are i
iconic of the sort of conflict that this
has become this david and goliath
struggle so in saying what they say
it really matters to kiev and probably
to the rest of the world
that nothing remains but to fight